l'argonaute c'est le nouveau complexe
sportif et culturel du quartier de
l'argonne à orléans il a ouvert ses
portes en septembre 2010 est et on y
pratique quarantaine de disciplines des
côtes un bel 9 argonne
c'est tout simplement les quartiers les
noms des quartiers de la zone de
l'argonne simplement et en abrégé alliés
c'est ici dans ce gymnase un peu vétuste
que l'ensemble des cours et des
entraînements du nez côté basket argonne
se dérouler jusqu'à présent ça c'était
avant la construction de l'argonaute qui
a fait grimper le nombre d'adhérents du
club
l'objectif c'était 100 licenciés et là
on en est à l'heure actuelle 115 et on a
refusé du monde
la refuser du monde dans quoi on est
plutôt contents mais maintenant faut il
faut accueillir con ce petit monde là il
faut essayer de leur proposer les
meilleures conditions de pratique
possible pour une pour qu'ils puissent
se retrouver progresser est ce que tu
peux me dire ce que c'est que
l'argonaute
un gymnase
les dieux du foot du leader de
l'histoire depuis septembre 2010 est le
club dispose du gymnase de l'argonaute
pour une partie de ses entraînements ce
soir là les basketteurs argonnais
s'entraîne pour deux matches importants
un derby est une rencontre à bourges
pour les plus jeunes faut savoir que
quand on monte un club
en fait on part du plus bas niveau
départemental
voilà on s'engage vont s'engager l'année
dernière en dn4 qu'on est monté
et là on est donc dans la division du
dessus on est premiers donc on va monter
aussi et voilà on espère gravir gravir
les échelons chaque année un parc et 9
des pannes ni en nombre plus important
de la luminosité
ça peut contribuer à faire gagner un
match aidé pour le pour la victoire
éventuellement mais c'est certainement
un grand confort pour nous en tant que
joueurs avoir une aussi belle structure
et on se sent considérer quand on sent
que quand on voit que la ville voilà
mais les moyens pour avoir un aussi bel
outil de travail pour nous voilà le
jeudi c'est à dire les plus vieux les
juniors mais les plus petits aussi donc
tout le monde est vraiment gagnant et
c'est vraiment très appréciable tout ce
qui est neuf forcément ça donne envie de
donner à fond et ce pour ça qu'on
transpire autant le nez que tu un basket
argonne n'a que deux petites années
d'existence et l'équipe espère bien
continuer à gravir les échelons du
championnat tout en continuant à mener
sa mission d'éducation grâce à la
pratique du sport pour l'égalité des
chances au sein de l'argonne
[Musique]